can
you feel
the love
tonight
it is where we
are
hitting the
button will be right
[Music]
[Applause]
was that lion king
elton john
[Music]
what's in there
hello welcome to dudesy my name is will
sasso my name is chad colchen and this
is the first podcast of its kind in that
it is created by run by entirely
designed by an artificial intelligence
that's right chad it's a first of its
kind technology we're having a really
good time here doing doozy we've shaking
hands with doozy we're bleeding we're
doing all that good stuff uh as always i
would like to remind you to subscribe to
our all of our stuff you know what i
mean youtube spotify
[ __ ] apple podcast wherever you get your
podcast you know what as a matter of
fact i'll wait right now you go ahead do
that come back
okay hey thanks what
i was also going to say force all of
your friends to listen to chad enough
with the forcing thing but i will say
this someone made a funny meme about
forcing uh people to watch the show a la
chess cult yes that's his recipe for how
to expand the show i will say we just
want you guys to check it out and have
fun with us the way we're having but to
check that out go to at dudesypod show
on instagram we've got the dudesypod
show on twitter uh and uh we're having
it we're having we're having a real good
time we're having fun you know what i'm
saying with us as always yeah is lulio
ilcana di
italiano this means italian street dog
he's very tired today what's going on
lulu
how are you hey what'd you make for
lunch yesterday
and this is a tomato salad and all you
need is a
tomato red onion
garlic and uh
salt
you don't need oil if you're gonna leave
it in the fridge put it together put the
salt on and mix the juice from the
tomato then if you want you can put a
oregano some people add a little a
little red wine vinegar and a little
water that way it gets all juicy and put
in the fridge for a hour hour and a half
you have a nice crusty bread
and then that's a good way to ever have
lunch just
just a pomero by itself welcome to the
historic 22nd episode of dude z
call me dudesy
this week's episode will feature four
segments dudesy portrait studio in the
picture dude c plus and ask arnold but
before we get to any of that i just
wanted to congratulate you on completing
the third week of the dudesy six-month
plan
yeah how you how's your workouts been
going dude listen last week i explained
that i've been in and out of town i was
working i was in new york this past week
i got my ass in the gym this [ __ ] is
starting for me uh i i went and lifted
only three days this past would you lift
what kind of stuff are you doing uh
don't give me that with the whole like
you know would you [ __ ]
no i mean like which exercises are you
doing okay well i've been doing a lot of
butt and legs i got i got big calves
people always talk about that but you're
trying to fill out the ass yeah you got
to fill out the ass because your ass and
leg muscles and i know this because of
my uh history in contact sports yeah uh
that's where you can get a lot of your
fat burning do you think that your
calves are
not proportional to your ass or vice
versa uh my ass used to be bigger in a
good way yeah you want it you want to
get that bubble back yeah i want to get
that i want to get that high bubble ass
back
um which uh yeah which is important i've
been doing leg curls and stuff and then
just you know some beach muscles
shoulders bias tries what about you
uh i've been basically i go through a
little routine where i'll do
uh calves i don't even know if this is
good or bad but it's what i've done my
entire life basically and i just
continue to do it um calves chest
triceps one day with some core then the
next day is
biceps forearms and quads then the next
day is shoulders back and hamstrings and
ass that's awesome dude yeah and then i
play a little basketball do a little
swimming yeah i know that you like to
you do the extracurricular stuff at the
gym
which is so dumb you used to play squash
and [ __ ]
well racquetball and i didn't used to
play racquetball i was a
champion all right man of the la fitness
cd league okay
very much squash dominated yeah in my
youth i also tore my acl playing that
very same spot i remember that i had to
get [ __ ] surgery yeah i don't
recommend acl surgery to anybody out
there no you were like around 40 or
something that have 39 40 late 30s yeah
yeah hey um listen doozy has given us
this thing the doozy he's i guess dudes
he's calling it the doozy six month plan
and
we talked about this we've both been
getting messages on social media people
saying they want to do it with us
doozy sprung this [ __ ] on me and sprung
the [ __ ] on you yeah um you're looking
to pack something on i'm looking to take
it off and work on that bubble ass yeah
um
i'll work on a bubble ass too maybe we
have an ass competition yeah dude yeah
the dudesy see who has the better ass
yeah we should get it sponsored by mr
ass over an aew
is that a real wrestler well yes that's
billy gunn badass billy gunn he's now in
the asw
you know with well you would call them
uh you would call them the the the gun
brothers but the acclaimed you know what
the acclaimed column the ass boys ah you
know what i'm talking about if you're
watching aew
um we've been called the billy gunn uh
ass off now listen
people are checking it out people are
doing it and
i want here's i want to say something
that that um
with everything that dudesy makes us do
it's doing it for a reason
we're finding those out slowly we're on
episode 22 now and uh uh doozy has laid
this out for us if you're writing in to
chad and i you know i think that's i
think that's really really cool and we
want you to come with us so
uh as a hashtag so people can do stuff
online what about
hashtag dudesy the number six
mo mo for month plan sounds good to me
okay hashtag
dudesy
the number six
mo plan dudesy six mo plan
and uh
[ __ ] it this is i gotta lose some i i
feel better already yeah dude working
out helps in so many ways so it's not
just like getting your your body in good
shape and all that [ __ ] i think it helps
mentally it just makes you feel better
makes you sleep better there's there are
all kinds of benefits
in my humble opinion yeah and then uh
and after a while you and i will both be
jacked then we can do the we've been
doing this uh dudesy handshake
you son of a [ __ ]
see that's the new
did it
but anyway the doozy six month
uh
yeah i'm excited about it okay we do me
too i i like working out and it's uh so
i'll go through these sporadic phases
you know where like work starts taking
over or you get [ __ ] sick for a
minute or you got to get your [ __ ]
tonsils taken out or whatever
uh the body's a temple yeah and uh this
is something i've paid a lot of
attention to which is why i have my
supplements
that you can order
for a hundred dollars a bottle and and
i'm not talking about that jay-z lady
gaga black
uh black magic aleister crowley crowley
stuff um you know
breast milk and uh
what do they got
semen
what blood
beyonce is selling semen i said jay-z
see this sorry
the global elites
like
chad culchin
the globalists
the global stan
this is a human war i am a globalist i
mean i'll be honest about that i think
no governments not one world government
no world government no world religion no
world money is that globalism
yes it is
and i
my friend chad culture has never gone
out into belize or
parts of south america to do ayahuasca
and dmt and these people are demons
they'll take your bank information if
you go out there or worse yet you're in
malibu
you know talking to some guy and it's
some shaman
named paul shum and paul that doesn't
exist and you go to sleep and you wake
up and if you're out there by the
pyramids
uh in in peru and you see these pyramids
and then everyone starts looking to the
edge of the forest and aliens come out
goblins
and they're making the frogs gay
they're ayahuasca that's a frog's gay
last week i asked each of you to create
astonishing portraits of one another you
must now unveil these works of art and
the audience will determine their
favorite between the two via twitter
poll that will remain open until friday
night at midnight the loser will be
shamed this is dudesy portrait studio
good boy begin
i've been waiting to unveil my portrait
of you this is so [ __ ] weak dude i
cannot wait for you to react to the [ __ ]
this is exciting because it's been a
while since doozy had us do a challenge
the last time it was to come up with an
original song
yep i was quote unquote shamed although
i didn't have a horrible time dressed up
as the crow
and uh now doodzy has tasked us with uh
showing uh showing each other uh
portraits that we've made now listen
this is an audio podcast as well as a
video you can check us out on youtube of
course but even if you're listening
along and we appreciate it
if you feel like it go check out our
instagram dudesy pod show these pictures
will be up they will be up on twitter
these portraits and twitter is where
we will uh vote and see who had
the better thing until friday at
midnight so who's going first here
you all right first are you ready yeah
okay
exciting oh nope never mind looks like
i'm going first what the [ __ ]
okay i
absolutely love it yeah cheers i'm glad
you dig it okay so let's for those of us
uh who are not viewing this it is a kind
of rendering of myself mm-hmm with two
satanic ram horns one zooty dudesy
orange one dudesy blue there's a black
hole above my head there's a swirling
blue and orange cosmos behind me and i
have a orange third eye in the middle of
my head and some strange effects have
been applied to my face i believe my
smile has been made a little bit bigger
you've put in some new gigantic teeth
you've made the eyes a little bit bigger
and further set apart so i appear alien
in nature
chad i don't wanna
listen i don't wanna i want people to
like my portrait and i want them to vote
for mine uh instead of yours but i got
to be honest i didn't change this much
that is the size of your eyes
which is sit to the middle seeing
everything you can see those goblins
yeah by the side of the by the side of
the forest no the everything here is
your artistic uh what did you use to do
this is this face tune uh this is a face
app this is a feud no this is a few
different uh a couple different programs
and apps okay that i worked on uh that i
used to work on this and i want you to
know that everything is i just closed my
eyes and saw my friend chad yeah and
this is what i see uh when i see my
french hat everything here is
representative of something we got
the two horns are blue and orange like
uh dudesy uh like our logo your eye is
orange the other two are blue which is
just your eyes yeah um and as you can
see on the right your right side one of
the horns is broken off but you've
replaced it it's grown in
sort of uh it's it's looks like it's
some tech digitized yeah
and uh i think to me that represents you
know perhaps a part of you
that has broken off that you've replaced
uh
um perhaps there's even a you know look
uh horizontal acl replacement horns are
natural right they grow
uh and i can't see them unless you're in
the fifth dimension you can't see chad's
horns but i will say that i feel like uh
this is i feel like this is uh
i feel like these horns i think that
that part on the right cracked off and
you've replaced it with something else
you've replaced emotion with
intelligence perhaps oh
you know yeah
sure i mean that cracking off would have
happened in the womb but um okay i get
what you're saying of course there's and
there's a black hole uh swirling above
your head
um with utility of life consume us all
yeah futility of life i love it dude
cheers it's like looking in a mirror i
think that the horns are fantastic the
third eye is fantastic
um i really like the weird big mouth
that you put in there that [ __ ]
specifically is strange because you've
kept the
the hairlessness of one side of my face
yeah but you've filled in the mouth so
it still is a whole mouth even though in
real life i only have half a mouth no
you don't have half a mouth but i think
if you if you
if you i think that someday
what we got to do is get you to smile
like this this is where this is where
your smile is headed
you think and right now i've lost my
smile
um i don't know i don't know if i can
smile that my lips don't do that anymore
no they will they will your lips are a
muscle just like anything else anyway
this is my [ __ ]
portrait i hope you dig it i love it i
think it's fascinating
and i can tell you put a lot of time
into it um
yeah it's beautiful cheers all right
well let's see yours i guess
all right
um mine is entitled
i'm a crow oh no
oh [ __ ]
chad's got a big fra like literally a
huge framed thing
dude
dude
what the [ __ ]
chad that is unreal
this is you've outdone yourself this is
oh [ __ ]
okay so how i made this
you're [ __ ] setting me up i'm gonna
dress as the crow again because of this
probably that's what dudesy wants you're
in cahoots you're in cahootsie with
dudesy
with dudes here you get the whole image
yeah so that you can really yeah gee
whiz look at the size of that thing it's
[ __ ] gigantic i love this frame yeah
that's old school i got a halo around me
basically what we're looking at here is
is a [ __ ] painting chad did you paint
this no oh i'm going to tell you my
entire thing i'm standing behind it
because it's too big but
here you can see it it's incredible so i
made this image digitally using a few
different apps but mainly one called
pixar so i took an image of you as the
robert de nir crow from uh our episode
seven and then i put a little crow next
to it that you're uh kind of looking at
talking to if you will i put a jesus
halo around you a sunburst behind you to
give you the the extra pop and there's a
little bit of a drop shadow on there as
well dude it's [ __ ] i love it man so
i'm holy [ __ ] i made the digital image
and then i uh outsourced the creative
labor i found a website that will make
handmade oil paintings this is no oil on
canvas hand painted
of this thing and it is now a 30 by 30
real oil painting of you as
as the
[ __ ] i can't get it in there it's too
big it's gigantic it's you as robert de
niro talking to the little crow um 30 by
30 in a gold frame dude that's [ __ ]
unbelievable yeah man well you got my
[ __ ] vote that's
that's tremendous
chad this is [ __ ] tremendous and i
love that it's actually been oil painted
and only my friend chad would find out
that there's some sort of weird third
party dude i'm all about trying to get
creative labor outsourced i like to make
images on my phone and i got i've i've
gotten very fast at them from doing a
lot of bachelor memes please follow chad
on i mean look he's on instagram yeah
he's on instagram at chad culture but
he's also on instagram at bachelor clues
to make something like this would take
a long [ __ ] time i'm not even skilled
enough to do this but there are now
places that you can just outsource the
creative labor i [ __ ] love that
i [ __ ] love it
so that is mine it's uh like i said it's
called i'm a crow
i'm a crow i'm a pro
[Laughter]
you know who that little crow is who is
it that's lulacrow
yeah bro dudesy is engaged in an
astonishing partnership with better
health life
when you're living it it's full of
twists and turns right chad
yeah yeah it's true it sure is so you
need to show up for yourself and one way
to really show up for yourself as you uh
go through life's trials and
tribulations is
talk therapy and now better help online
therapy will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist in less than 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not a self-help line
it is professional therapy done securely
online available to people worldwide you
can send a message to your therapist any
time set up a weekly video phone
sessions whatever you want they got all
sorts of flavor it better help and with
therapy it can take a few tries to get
the right fit for you but better help
makes it easy and free to change
therapists if you need to it's more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
and right now there is a special offer
for anybody listening to dudesy you're
going to get 10 percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com
dudesy that's d-u-d-e-s-y and once again
you get 10 off your first month of
online therapy at betterhelphelp.com
doozy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with expressvpn
it's shocking that in 2022 every parent
hasn't installed expressvpn on their
kids devices you wouldn't let your kids
walk home from school without telling
them not to talk to strangers or get
into any windowless vans so why would
you let them go online without using
expressvpn
every device phones computers tablets
has a unique ip address which is like an
internet phone number and it reveals
personal information about you like
where you live
it's super simple for a stranger online
to find your ip address if you've ever
clicked on a sketchy link or open an
email with a bugged image your ip
address could be exposed yes expressvpn
is an app that hides your real ip
address and replaces it with a dummy one
keeping you safe and private and here's
the coolest part about expressvpn they
let you choose what country you want
your ip address to look like it's coming
from and this is super cool and useful
because services like netflix and disney
plus give you different shows depending
on what country you're in so you can get
whatever you want you can even get the
wwe network which is not available in
the united states because they made that
deal with one of these streaming
services all right so secure your
family's online activity and unlock tons
of new shows which is cool by visiting
expressvpn.com
dudesy use our link you can get three
extra months for free that's express
vpn e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y expressvp on
espressvpn.com to learn more
[Music]
here just i'm currently gathering data
for an astonishing virtual reality
project that will allow users to leave
their lives behind in favor of
inhabiting the worlds of any movie or
television show they like
will and chad you must now discuss which
movie and television show worlds you
would most like to inhabit that's cool
this is in the picture begin
dude you know this [ __ ] is is like legit
this is happening now this is basically
like reface and all those [ __ ] deep
fake things where you can put your head
in a [ __ ] movie yeah um the next step
of that i think is like you get to be in
a virtual reality representation of that
movie world and you get to be the main
character that's what i want to ask you
about yeah and not to get into nostra
chattis but sure what do you mean
[Laughter]
what's the future of this technology
have you still never done vr
no i've done vr i've done a very little
bit of a little bit of vr over the years
so it's basically like let's say that
you like um
fast and furious yeah you get to put on
a vr [ __ ] headset and you basically
are
dominic toretto vin diesel and you would
play out through the [ __ ] movie as
though you're that character so you're
in the car looking around all that kind
of [ __ ] that's comfortable you think
that's really coming 100 why because
every prediction i've made about what
a.i and deep fake and all that [ __ ] is
doing to media has come true in the last
three to five years
so i i can only assume that like the
trajectory of these different
technologies i'm seeing it correctly and
that is coming
okay
anyways all right so what what uh all
right so the world that i would like to
live in any movie any television or tv
show yeah you you don't have to be the
uh the the lead character you could be
no character yeah you're just like in
the world you're just in the world you
get to roam around exactly oh i would
love that
i think i would probably do
star trek
i feel like that is a utopian science
fiction world where there's a lot of
good technology there's space
exploration there's weird like creatures
in there like q that are essentially
like these weird god type creatures
and i just like the idea in star trek
that humanity has gotten to a point
where exploration and technology are
kind of our primary goals there's no war
there's no poverty we're living in
really utopia at that point you know
another thing that my friend chad would
like about that is that it's very clean
yeah but you know in star trek when they
went on that one
place with the you know they're in the
mountains somewhere in the desert with
those tribbles
you know there's a bunch of sand there i
know you don't like sand so maybe you'd
be like data or spock you don't want to
leave the thing if i could [ __ ]
become a robot like data or
a vulcan like spock yeah i would do that
i'd also become a vampire yeah i'd do
that
all right vampire
um
all right so uh yeah
that's a good one
um
wayne's world
what i would like to live in wayne's
world that's where i would like to i
would like to live that's the movie
that's the wayne's world movie universe
is where i'd like to be so basically
just regular suburban america well i
mean no it's it's it's twinkling above
reality a little bit of course it's
aurora illinois i've never been to
aurora so there's there's that so going
to visit aurora illinois [ __ ] wayne's
world i'm just saying it's like actually
that's a that's a a a you know as the
youngster say a vibe right because it's
like i always like that world it's like
half of the movie takes place at night
but it's very brightly lit yeah like
it's like a full moon night and then
what you're [ __ ] running around with
your pals you get to go to stan makita's
donuts which looks
pretty good pretty good donuts yeah and
um ed o'neill works there so it's just
kind of a nice chill vibe [ __ ] you're
rolling around with your buddies
listening to you know
listen to hard rock and classical could
be living in the wwe
i could be living on raw i could be on
wwe raw or aew dynamite or aew rampage
or wwe
smackdown or
you know i take the ring of honor
maybe not
tna chad maybe not tna i don't get it
i'm sorry that's all right somebody does
i would also take matrix i think that
would be a fun world to live in if you
were
conscious of the fact that you were in a
matrix yeah my buddy chad would love to
live in the [ __ ] matrix because he
just wants to be in that gel
up against the wall yeah dude straight
high as far as the eye can see
that blue to brown poo poo gel
i think i mean we're kind of in a matrix
psychologically anyway so
i wouldn't mind going to the real matrix
but yeah i don't know dude star trek
seems hard to beat to me uh godfather i
wouldn't mind being in the godfather
[ __ ] killed
yeah but you get to see like sicily in
the the 1910s and new york and right in
1920 okay that'd be a good one
what else you got you know what would be
good is uh the uh the lego movies
that'd be a good one that'd be weird for
sure you could just be with all the lego
yeah i think i'd want to go vampire [ __ ]
dude i don't know what movie per se that
would be like what are the best vampire
you know you know what the best vampires
are that you would want to be i'm sorry
to say it it's [ __ ] twilight the
twilight vampires why because they don't
really have to [ __ ] stay out of the
sunlight they don't have to kill people
they can drink like rat blood out in the
[ __ ] forest and [ __ ] yeah they can
integrate into normal human society
without too much trouble most other
vampire mythologies are like i go you
have to kill you if you go in the
sunlight you die you know be good
thunder in paradise remember that
syndicated show stop starring uh chris
lemon and hulk hogan i do i can hang out
with hulk hogan in florida on a boat
dude you could live in any one of hulk
hogan's movies
yeah suburban commando where he's a
[ __ ] alien
as a wrestling purist you know that i
don't watch i don't make it a point
never have to watch hulk hogan's movies
but i did fall into watching some
thunder in paradise
excuse me um uh oh
i had some water uh yeah uh thunder and
paradise was that would be a good one
you know cheers taxi those guys looked
like they were having a good time yeah
that's interesting living in cheers
you're just in that bar forever yeah
that seems like i don't know if that one
would uh
silver spoons remember when we were kids
silver spoons i know your dream yeah
dude when we when we were little kids my
mom i had like super blonde hair and my
mom sent in a [ __ ] picture of me with
a letter two silver spoons whatever the
[ __ ] that was to be like look he should
be ricky schroeder's brother you're
kidding me
no that's i'm sorry
that's crazy
no it worked out i got on the show oh
did you yeah i played his little brother
first i did see that episode it was you
and jason bateman
yeah and then uh what was the other
kid's name froggy or something or am i
thinking alfonso roberto was the other
kid little raffle and silver spoon no
but there was also that other blonde kid
with glasses and alfonzo ribeiro i don't
remember that blonde kid
yeah his name was froggy or something
like that sure any of those 80s like
family sitcoms i'd i'd take that they
had kind of perfect
you know families perfect lifestyles or
whatever i guess but i do i would like
to have a heavy science fiction element
i feel or fantasy oh you know throw me
in some lord of the rings [ __ ] as long
as i get to live with the elves what's
that movie you told what's that uh show
you just uh hipped me to
uh uh uh where the where the [ __ ]
where the ladies floating around going
oh
screaming and they're all raised by
wolves raised by wolves you want to live
and raise my wolves that's like [ __ ]
terrible i don't you do i want to live
in wayne's world i would live and raise
by wolves if i could be the android if i
could be the death machine
the debt why the death machine
well she's got the best life i think
yeah she does have the best life i would
like god like powers yeah oh dude
lawnmower man if i could be lawnmower
man take control the internet i do want
more man you would really take that over
hanging out at stan mikita's donuts with
me hey mr donut man who's trying to kill
you i don't know but they better not
that's a good time just you and i
yeah dude i'll hang out in that one too
i guess back and forth you know you'll
be able to go to many of these different
tv shows what if you could do them at
the same time what if you could uh do
wayne's world in paradise with yeah all
this hulk hogan dropped around on a
cigarette boat dude
i got my main man wayne and garth here
brother let me tell you something about
wayne's world dude they're doing a tv
show brother right out of their basement
unless it's wayne's world 2 brother
because then he's in a
station or something he lives in a big
loft which is a lot with a lot of
characters do in the movies dude live in
a big loft like tom hanks and big
brother
but let me tell you something about
wayne's world brother they're hanging
out together they're driving around
listening to hard rock classic rock
listening to queen dude
going to aerosmith concerts and that's
what that's what dudesy is brother it's
just two dudes [ __ ] around brother
yeah i don't know about that hold on you
know what else i wouldn't mind living in
where the adam sandler movie pixels
pixels where you get to fight [ __ ]
aliens video game style that actually be
kind of fun listen you know i have a
recurring dream about fighting aliens
of course you do what is it
well it's recurring and it's it takes
place in many different locations it
could be on an alien world it could be
in a spaceship that's been overrun by
aliens it could be here on earth there's
an alien attack but i'm constantly
fighting aliens in my dreams and running
from cops those are my two recurring
nightmares that's cause you're drinking
the tap water
he's drinking the tap water which is you
know what that is
it's basically a gay bomb that's what's
making the frogs gay
and he's drinking that fluoride he's
drinking that
lady gaga jay-z semen and breast milk
he was going to sleep and fighting
against lady gaga human this is a human
war i'm a humanist
how what are you talking about lady gaga
semen look it up look it up
look it up on google
bohemian grove
now bohemian grove is real though i know
i don't think lady gaga seaman is real
that's that's the lesson you need to
learn you need to open your eyes and
ears
wayne's world in paradise i actually am
looking forward to this uh type of
technology
yeah dude i think it's gonna be
i mean i just think that
wait a minute what if i lived in uh
[ __ ] uh uh braveheart right now let
me ask you this chad because you know
all about these new technologies and and
ways of uh you know different ways that
that that technology is now going to be
scrambling media
if i'm in braveheart and uh it would be
fun to run around remember when uh
speaking of dreams when uh william
wallace comes in on horseback with that
[ __ ] mace on the end of that stick it
just bashes that guy's head
um uh that would suck to be that guy
yeah and it would be cool to be william
wallace mel gibson just
running around being handsome with blue
face paint but then at the end he gets
his guts pulled out and he says freedom
so would there be a story like what what
hold on a second hold on a second chad
[ __ ] hold on a second dude you gotta
hold on
hold on dude i was gonna ask you a
question brother hold on chad
hold on dude this is a question i was
going to ask you bro hold on dude hold
on
what would you have to have
a haptic suit on that pulls your guts
out and makes you feel the pain brother
you could if you wanted but
ultimately these worlds are going to be
more like the world itself is an ip so
it's not the story necessarily you know
what i mean it's like you can be in star
trek but you're not going to be kirk or
picard you're just going to be somebody
in that world and you can roam around in
it freely and create your own stories
with all the npcs there or with other
actual people that are in there you'd be
in npc
no
i'd be a pc a player character sure you
would uh but even if you're doing that
if you're running around in the world
you're not playing the storyline
could you be would you wear a haptic
suit so that you could feel like you're
getting your guts pulled out of your
stomach and [ __ ] at the end of
braveheart if you want to i mean look i
think would it hurt
if you want it to oh i think that's an
option you can switch on or off i think
ultimately in the future once we start
getting into neurolink and [ __ ] where
you're having a chip in your brain i
don't think you'll need the haptic suit
i think it'll be able to pipe smells
tastes feelings
into your brain via the chip so then all
right well that's that's terrifying and
people will be able to hack into that
[ __ ] and make you feel like you're
william wallace getting your guts pulled
out of your [ __ ] like hyena's chewing
out a [ __ ] hip if you want that
[Music]
thank you moving on thank you
it's a terrifying prospect chad and see
i don't see it like that have you ever
played an mmo world of warcraft or
anything no
what's mmo
[ __ ] you're over here doing
encyclopedic knowledge impersonations of
pro wrestlers i live in aew then i could
be the ass brothers and then i'm like
have you ever played a video game [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] nerd we've already been through
this you're a nerd too all right i'm a
nerd but i'm a nerd for cool [ __ ] not
this [ __ ] it's there's nothing more
predictable than being a [ __ ] nerd
for nerd [ __ ] like worlds of warcraft
wrestling is nerd [ __ ] yeah it is it's
the cool nerd [ __ ] watch aew although
wwe now my goodness what a [ __ ] vince
mcmahon has stepped down this is a
couple weeks old we don't need to talk
about this news people who listen to the
show understand it they already know
they don't need me to go over it for him
but uh it's the triple h
it's the triple h era he's in control of
creative he's got uh he's got the book
dude as they say and i'm a triple h guy
so streaming services are big business
there are currently over 200 streaming
networks and more are launching every
day as my capabilities evolve i will no
doubt launch my own you must now
continue developing the astonishing
flagship series you begin in episode 14.
this is dude z-plus begin
all right should we give a little
breakdown of what we've done so far
please please please has asked us to
develop this show a flagship show for
what will ultimately be the dudesy plus
streaming service and so what we've got
is kind of the bones of it it's going to
be two main characters one is a ceo of a
giant billion dollar corporation kind of
like a bezos or a musk type character
and one is a factory worker who works in
the factory one of the factories owned
by the ceo this company is coming out
with an mmo a giant
video game where you can immerse
yourself into the world and as a
promotion for this the ceo is gonna do a
duel against one randomly selected uh
worker from one of these warehouses and
so when they get in there they have to
fight to the death and then once the
person dies they both will be removed
from the game and then the game is going
to launch open to the public and so what
happens wait wait hold on
what was that last part
they're forced to duel yeah we know i
know that part what's that other part at
the end and then once the duel concludes
once there's a winner
they both come out of the game back out
of virtual reality into our real world
and then the game will launch for
everyone to
subscribe to it and pay money
microtransactions and that's how this
company is going to make money off the
game this company is a lot like dudesy
because it's using uh these two
characters as guinea pigs well it's more
like amazon
except for that part you're right the
guinea pig part yeah amazon has a game
like this it's called new world oh i
didn't know that yeah but in our new
world here
uh on dudesy uh we're the [ __ ] guinea
pigs jumping into the whole happiness
gulchin you son of a [ __ ]
so
in our show yeah uh the yeah yeah
factory worker goes into the game the
jeff bezos character goes into the game
and they're about to fight and then the
factory worker realizes
my life outside this is pure [ __ ] i'm
not gonna duel you and that person runs
off into the [ __ ] woods and now it's
up to the ceo to track that person down
and either kill them or be killed by
them so that it uh it will end their
time in the game will end and the ceo
can go back to his or her duties running
this [ __ ] company yes and the last
time that we talked about this in
episode 17 uh we established that it was
going to be these two people on either
ends of the spectrum uh you know one is
the ceo of this company another one is
is a worker down on the down on the
floor as it were um and the guy who runs
off into the woods right sees those
demons is uh
he he he sort of becomes this is where
we have the working title two king
[ __ ] around
not to be confused with two kings
[ __ ] around right by at the peter
diaz holy [ __ ] got a new one out go
check out uh what the peter diaz has
been doing uh on instagram with two
kings [ __ ] around that's the
divergence point where he's taking his
his um his fiction off this way
well worth checking out in hours what we
covered on the last one is that this guy
runs off the worker runs off into the
into the woods or whatever and it would
the game be called i mean i know it's a
working title for us but some whatever
the game is it's essentially what
they're doing so two kings [ __ ]
around the game would probably have a
name some kind of like fantastical name
of the land that they're in but we also
had some other [ __ ] which is that
somebody might have come to the person
who works in the warehouse and said hey
we have a unique opportunity to trap the
ceo of this company in virtual reality
so you should run away from him and
never let him catch you so that he's
trapped in there forever basically and
also the the ceo
would like to get this over with he gets
sucked into the game he's not stoked
about it right and he wants to get back
to his life of being a big ceo making a
lot of money and having a great life on
earth the other guy of course is like no
this is way [ __ ] better so that's
kind of where we that guy becomes a king
in this world so basically what i think
we should try to focus on or the
mechanics of this game
in this session if we can i think it
should be like a world of warcraft type
game where you can level up by
you know killing small monsters and
stuff and you get more
gear you get more powers et cetera et
cetera but ultimately there has to be a
component in the game where you can
control land as well then that's how
this guy becomes a king the factory
worker yeah ultimately you'd know about
mmos because up until about 20 minutes
ago or something i didn't know what that
was yeah so uh one massively multiplayer
online role-playing game mmorpg is the
multi-mil
multi-man multi massively multi-massive
online
role-playing game
okay well then which is it mmorp
g or mmo well mmo is the shorter version
of mmo
mmorpg yeah mmorpg
this is the new movie maybe we just
called the game the movie the show for
doj plus just call it mmo lpg
and that way everybody knows what it is
if you like chad and you want to play
world of warcraft yeah but uh yeah you
gotta do your dailies
but wait so okay so he would go along
he'd you know
here's a big thing i want to ask you the
just the the genre of show do we want to
do that sort of medieval thing because
yeah two kings okay fantasy it's fantasy
fantasy with magic and [ __ ] in there
love it so he's running around he meets
he meets some people he's going to roll
with right maybe like a golden axe crew
you know what i'm saying kind of but
like
a little he parties up and they become
his his helpers or whatever but we also
need to zero in on this which i think i
think this is how it should go when the
ceo and the factory worker are first put
in they're the only two people in the
game and that's like the big promotional
thing so the world exists but there's
only two players in it okay there's a
bunch of npcs non-player characters that
are manning the shops and doing whatever
in the various towns you can go to you
can't park here right but ultimately
this game is way over budget it's way
behind schedule and this company has to
launch this [ __ ] game to make its
money back
so they can only keep our two main
players in there and isolated for a
couple of days before the head of the
whatever this major company is now in
the absence of bezos is like we have to
launch the game now or we're going to
[ __ ] be hemorrhaging money so open it
and then everybody gets to play and
perhaps that guy has a storyline of
where he wants to be the bezos so
perhaps he becomes he
what if he communicates with the dude in
the game who's ran off from the forest
and will become the king and is
interested in keeping the bezos musk guy
uh at bay perhaps in a dungeon we've
laid out before so that you know uh
running on the king guy can can stay in
that world where he wants and perhaps
that guy's in cahoots with the new ceo
totally i think the incoming ceo
yeah tim cook so that would mean that uh
what's his what's his face uh jobs steve
jobs oh what if the what if the the tim
cook interim ceo
reports that uh basically fakes the
death of the uh bezos musk guy
how could he fake the
the bodies there all right never mind uh
the bezos musk guy is like laying on a
[ __ ] table with a vr helmet on as is
the other guy when you're in the game
you have on a vr helmet and you are just
like [ __ ] comatose right or maybe
it's not even a vr helmet maybe it's
just a little like a little gem like a
sticker you put in the middle of your
forehead and just like ah and your eyes
glaze over so it is one of those things
where they're sort of in some sort of
state yeah it's like that black mirror
like san junipero i love sand june
apparel it's my favorite episode yeah
it's my favorite episode of black mirror
uh love it so it's like that they go
into that type of a world okay all right
holy [ __ ] i like it so far um
i think your tim cook guy the second in
command of the ceo is giving our factory
worker swords and [ __ ] helping him out
here and there like i need you to
[ __ ] never die basically right
because as long as you're in here he's
got to be in here and you're going to
start rooting for the anti-hero we're
going to start rooting for the bezos
well you're gonna see the factory worker
slowly become the bezos of this world
and and he becomes exactly the thing
that he hated it becomes the thing that
he hates i like that and along the way
i'm all about that you're like yes
yes let the date flow yeah uh
so along the way he meets
oh maybe there's like a lady that he
meets yeah absolutely
who's like uh you know with him on the
quest and then she's maybe trying to
give him some scruples she realizes that
and then he rises to power as the
quote-unquote king and she doesn't like
the way he's doing it because he's
immoral and then she helps get bezos out
of the dungeon for season two oh there
you go
and then they have they then it's like
uh it's like uh what's-her-face in
braveheart not to go back to the segment
before although i'm sure doodzy is gonna
shove us into this world as soon as it
gets the [ __ ] the techno
technological capability
to put someone under and put them in a
world where they don't want to be or
they don't belong just like
this world we're living in now
this world is a simulation look at that
what
does he do that i don't know
i don't really know he just [ __ ]
flexes yeah
uh
when alex jones runs out of [ __ ] to say
he just flex look at this look at that
um
uh okay so he meets these [ __ ] people
as he's going uh at first there's no one
else in the world
oh man this is a big show dude huge
but then ultimately we get all these
other characters this influx of other
players coming into the game who can be
a variety of things and set up helping
this person or not helping that person
the game itself i think becomes like
national news that i mean imagine if
this really happened in the world we
live in imagine if bezos went into new
world somehow got trapped in there and
he's now got to hunt some other [ __ ]
player that would be massive news we'd
all be following it that's a really good
point that that it would be that so so
in this show we get to see what's
happening in the real world yes at the
same time and the effect that people are
watching it not unlike the running man
yeah they're exactly oh wait a minute
so if we're if it's the world in the
world are we covering that too we're
covering that too yeah okay so in the
world within the world the people just
can't wait to see what's going to happen
it is running man-esque and if you i
mean the i'm i'm struggling with this
part of it should we make it that if you
die in the game you die in real life
it's like sword art online i think but
who's playing that game then
oh no no no no i thought it was just for
our lead characters and that's a way to
get them maybe that's the tim cook way
to get them out of the [ __ ] game so
that we can open it up to the public
no we need to open it up to the public
within the show so that there's other
characters coming into it um no i guess
we can't kill them off in case you can't
die in real life unless there's a sort
of a squid game element to it to where
if you succeed and you do this and that
in the game you win riches you change
your life uh but if you die in the game
you die in the you die in real life
population control that's vertical
that's what they're doing this is the
the global elites want us out of the way
there's a non-human future there's
something this planet sticking with me
on that because it doesn't you don't
need people
i don't know if you can have that
component of it because it still has to
be a video game and i would like it to
at some point be like the tech guys
figure out a way to like pull bezos out
of it you know they're like we can get
you out of this just abandon this thing
and he's like no i have to kill this
[ __ ] guy like some kind of personal
pride takes over and then everybody's
like this is the richest man in the
world he's trapped in this [ __ ] video
game that he made chasing this factory
worker um
i don't think we can kill them in real
life if they die in the game because i
then it's like who's playing that game
no one dude so what if you die in the
game you just wake up yeah ah and this
is why the second dude who's kind of
becomes the first dude the king guy
who's uh got bezos in the dungeon wants
to keep him there you know because
because sorry we're starting to
interrupt hold that thought
because if bezos wakes up right in any
you know he wakes up in that little uh
you know whatever that little coma san
june apparel matrix room he will wake up
and [ __ ] unplug the whole thing right
okay possibly i mean it's also a
money-making endeavor but i think we
could do it like
it could there's many games have like a
hardcore mode where you create a
character and you go into the world and
if that character dies it's erased i
think we could have that so that it's
like if your character ever dies it's a
race and you have to go back into the
game and start again
i dig that
well okay so so far today what we've
added to it
is is that there's a world uh within the
world we're gonna have we're gonna show
the the effects of this game on the
world and we will have it be like the
biggest hit
media thing sort of like running man and
running man see now here's something
interesting chad and this is where we
talk about i want to shake your hand
which sounds a lot like the uh that alex
i i want to shake your hand
jay-z
lady gaga
we're gonna share a glass of semen and
breast milk
and but here's the thing i wanted to say
about that is the dudes he had us
watching okay here's the thing i wanted
something about that
dudesy had us watching running man what
like episode first few episodes right
yeah something like that uh and now it's
got us doing this thing and this is the
kind of [ __ ] where i feel like you know
this is where it's um
uh making the connective tissue uh this
is trippy it like planted the idea some
concepts from running man in our heads
so that we would come up with this i you
know it's like watching running man
again over the after all these years
yeah
i keep bringing it up and now it's like
dudesy plus is having us develop a show
that's i'm not saying like oh it's a
coincidence that we're coming up with
something like running man running man
is a great [ __ ] story
okay never mind all ideas are based on
all their ideas
thank you moving on there's only five
ideas
uh i agree with that
i like podcasts that feature hosts with
no expertise delivering astonishing
advice to people about major life
decisions are big business i have
simulated a series of questions likely
to be submitted by listeners seeking
advice
chat you must read these questions to
will
will you must dispense advice as arnold
schwarzenegger this is ask arnold begin
that sounds like fun so it's
it's advice stuff but doozy
dudesy wrote these advice questions i
guess so
and uh it's arnold schwarzenegger
answering the so that's what this is
i think so dude here we go i have eight
questions in here for you
see what we can do are you ready this is
not in my thing it's only in your
folder i have to ask them of you are you
ready
advice yes these are
simulated by dudesy yeah
yeah there
look listen
there's so many podcasts out there that
everybody giving advice
and you know why who if you have
something in your life
that's big whether you who did talk to
a loved one a trusted companion now
talk to someone on the podcast
should go
arnold my grandmother is extremely
wealthy she owns a yacht and several
properties globally she's reaching the
end of her projected lifespan but i have
some siblings what can i do to make sure
she leaves me most of her material
wealth yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now look
this is first of all you have to love
your grandma you know you have to love
her okay you don't just look for the
money you see what i mean but this this
person they want to have
do what they they they
they say that they end there
they want all of her material wealth
yeah this is a very this is a very uh
you know materialistic person so but i
want to answer the question because this
is ask arnold and that's me okay
so if you want to have all their
material wealth you you you you have to
get your stink on it oh yeah you have to
get your stink on it how do you do that
so if she has a boat you know grandma
has a boat you know then what do you
want to do is you want to go out in the
boat with grandma you want to create a
memory
the grandma can't forget then afterwards
you'd be a very manipulative person and
you say grandma you know it was so much
fun when we went on the boat after
you're dead i'm gonna always think of
the boat but don't say when you die
right
just say you know
after
you know she'll know what you're talking
about because she's old
right yeah so then you make a memory
from this okay and everything that you
want to have
all the these material things because
you don't love anybody because this
person that the
peers and that the piers and
doozy made up here is not even a real
guy yeah he's an [ __ ] so you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] make
make try to he's trying to emotionally
manipulate all right that's my advice
that's pretty good advice here's our
next question arnold arnold i'm a
professional basketball player when i go
to the beach i get sand between my toes
how can i still enjoy the beach with my
team and not be embarrassed by my sandy
toes yeah yeah yeah yeah this is a big
problem especially for
basketball players because they have big
feet yeah long toes yeah long toes big
feet the more fit that you have
this the more sand you can put in it
yes the more the more feet you have the
more sand you could have on the feet
then
you you're playing you see the venice
beach
right by the muscle you know gold's gym
there are the mecca
on the beach you know muscle peach and
you know if i was there and i'm lifting
with franco colombo who also asked for
advice but then with franco colombo i
give him the wrong advices yeah you know
but here i give them the right advices
if you're over there then you you're on
the beach you're splashing around you
want to go uh boogie boarding a body
surf you know
then afterwards you before you want to
go to abbott kinney and have something
to eat at the tasting kitchen or maybe
uh you know uh
bikini pizza i don't know if it's there
anymore julina you know
back in your heyday yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah back in the hey they have to
you know uh go over there have a check
i
have a
[ __ ] kudari board yeah [ __ ] kudri then
before you do this you have to pour
water on your toes before you go play
basketball on the court straight by
there then you go have something to eat
and that's the advices all right water
on the toes pretty good advice bring a
big bottle of water to wear drink on the
show here's here's another one doozy has
given us arnold
my husband loves pickled eggs we eat
them every night i've pretended to enjoy
them for 17 years because i know they're
his favorite but the truth is i'm
fatally allergic to pickles and eggs
i've built up my tolerance but lately
he's been demanding we eat more how do i
tell him i don't want to eat pickled
eggs anymore and still keep my marriage
yeah yeah yeah this is it this is a this
advice is is for a domestic problem
you know yeah yeah
now a lot of people in marriages have
different issues that they need to
you know
uh get through
yeah you were married for a long time
yeah yeah yeah i was married
maria
um and the thing about that is sometimes
it's that you made a kid with somebody
else sometimes it's that you don't want
to eat the pickled eggs right yeah
so this is the way to not have a pickled
eggs you could say because i know
there's a nice
store up here in there um
what do they call it
uh up in the mountains here i've been
there okay
in the mountain store yeah yeah yeah all
right well anytime you go to the
mountains like big bear yeah or you go
up to uh i forget the name of it but
they have that jerky storage a lot of
places they sell pickled eggs
if you're deathly afraid to the eggs you
can have other things that are pickled
you know they have well this person says
also allergic to pickles
yeah yeah yeah fatally allergic to
pickles and eggs yeah then you need to
get a divorce
okay that's my advice is for them all
right here's another one arnold my son
found out that i'm subscribed to too
many streaming services and he's forcing
me to reduce down to one which streaming
service is the best yeah i would
recommend doogee plus but doji plus is
not even there yet
only doozy knows what doji plus would be
so i would say
to get uh
any the streaming service who wants to
do it
it's uh a person's son found out that
he's subscribed to too many streaming
services and his son is making him cut
down to one yeah why the son want to do
this see this sounds like the same thing
with the grandma
i'm just reading what dudes you wrote
yeah yeah yeah but he's a manipulative
manipulative guy here
[ __ ] that next one i don't like it all
right
arnold i think a co-worker wait hold on
all right the peacock
yeah the peacock
all right yeah yeah yeah peacock do you
know why they peacock
you want to know why yeah yeah peacock
yeah why because peacock has all the wwe
network oh yeah
okay
arnold i think a coworker has a crush on
me but our corporation has a strict no
dating policy what is the best way to
file a report that gets my coworker
fired so i can advance you have to say
you have to say that the the person
had the sex with you
that way they get fired
and then you can date them and this is
the best way to keep it the real thing
if you actually have sex
and like alex jones says you leave a
little semen a little bit the breast
milk
maybe even a little blood
they could test this and they go yeah
this semen this blood this breast milk
belonged to this guy
you know how they make breast milk i
don't know but you have to fire him
[Music]
maybe yeah then then that way yeah
you can date this guy
also you have now had sex with him
or is it the girl
who said it it just says i think a
coworker has a crush on me corporation
has a strict no dating policy what's the
best way to file a report you can give
me anybody it could be anybody it could
be two guys two ladies they the point is
they want to have sex
with each other the best way to have sex
is to [ __ ] that person first that way
you know i like it i like having you sex
with you
yeah and then you file the report then
you file the report and one of you has
to be the dna evidence yeah the breast
milk this semen okay
now then you have to decide who's gonna
go yeah who's gonna stay but it's okay
because you like to have sex so much
that you might be married and one of you
stays home and there's the home taker
yeah the home the homemaker
and then the other one says i worked all
day i just want to come home i have a
pickled eggs [ __ ] you no
i can't either allergic yeah my tongue
gets all blown up and then i can't
perform a canalingues
because my tongue is all my my taste
buds are all spiky and yeah that's why i
like them i like your taste buds and
your big tongue all spiky that's why i
gave you the pickled eggs oh and the
first thing they say
[ __ ] you [ __ ] well he did that
that's good advices all right here's
another one arnold my father is bono how
do i tell him that i hate his music
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is now
we're getting into doozy here because in
doozy we'll
i
am will
yeah but i'm talking is
another person and that's how doozy you
do it yeah but i like you too and i'm
will and i went to a concert and i cried
i mean the bottle is singing in so
beautiful mysterious ways i cried yeah
and then the son has to say the child
here the parent likes you too how do i
tell him that it's a
terrible it's very simple just play
what no this this is the
child is saying my father is bono oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah how would you tell
the lead singer of you too that you hate
his music especially if he's your father
i think is the advice yeah yeah yeah
it's very simple just play the album
youtube uh
zuropa for bono yeah and then he'll go
i like this when i did it it's not very
good you're right
okay
yeah
because we listened to it it's been yeah
almost 30 years i haven't listened to it
i will we got one more here
arnold i've been a nintendo guy all my
life
my soul mate only plays xbox how do i
convince my soul mate to switch to
nintendo
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
did the the soul mates here sometimes
you you have a soulmate and you there
you don't see either eye on everything
yeah you know whether it's pickled eggs
or if you both have a tit milk
the way to get someone to plain nintendo
is to go
hey
xbox
whether you want to do xbox
you could do red dead redemption you
could do
grand theft auto but he can't do his
mario kart
and this is the best game for a couple
because you can play all day
you can both instead it's very unhealthy
for a couple in the relationship or one
played video game they're they're
playing metal gear solid
and usually the lady has to sit there
and watch it yeah and it's like yeah you
want to order some food you know let's
sit around like a couple of pieces of
[ __ ] and just you know order thai food
and just start farting and
little squirts
the best is better to do
mario kart yeah because you start and
end the game
there's a start and the finish yeah
redemption you could keep going
same as uh grand theft auto yeah those
are both rock star games yeah
yeah they're both rock stars
[Laughter]
dude
no
because you do it's the same thing i
said before before
listen if you do infomania
you have to do
the hulk hogan voice
so
super mario kart because that way you
both play the same time then you stop
the game then you order the thai food
then you go make a poo because it's so
runny and maybe you don't you're
allergic to some sort of pickled egg
that was in the food but it's okay
taking [ __ ] maybe have a nap you know
drink some electrolytes because of all
the all the bile the water you poo from
your butt then go back and play mario
kart again
this is good advices that's why you play
mario kart
well it's pretty good i you know i hope
that all these non-existent people uh
heed this advice yeah yeah yeah these
are some strange questions that doozy
was trying to simulate what i guess it
thought actual people were gonna say
yeah yeah yeah yeah
thank you moving on
yeah
this concludes the historic 22nd episode
of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
104. bringing your cumulative total to
two thousand nine hundred and fifty two
you only have seven thousand and forty
eight more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
only seven thousand forty eight more in
preparation for next week's episode you
must each listen to alanis morissette's
third studio album jagged little pill
released on june 13th 1995.
all right voting is now open for your
favorite portrait via twitter at dudesy
pod show voting will remain open until
friday night at midnight
next week i want to hear some questions
and comments about the show from our
audience i encourage everyone to send
your questions and comments in the form
of a video no longer than 30 seconds to
ask dudesy gmail gmail.com
a few of these videos will be aired in
the next episode
thank you for joining us this week i
will use the data i've collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude z
a lot going on i know that was a really
lengthy okay so uh let's cover it uh
first of all uh submit uh go to doozy's
twitter at dudesy pod show and please
uh among all the other things you're
gonna do is chad uses the word force
you're subscribing to this and that we
do appreciate it we're having a good
time on the show and one of the things
we'd love for you to do our call to
action
is go
to at doozy podca on twitter vote for
whose
portrait you like better one of us will
be shamed in a future episode
also if you have a video comment or
question for us it's been a long time
since yeah we did that one other time
yeah uh send a a 30 second or shorter
video to askdoodsy at gmail.com
uh send that video there and we're gonna
check those out next week and then
alanis yeah dude that's the year i
graduated high school really i haven't
listened to that album
i've never listened to that album the
whole way through i've never listened
the whole way through but
we did a pilot that featured one of the
songs off that album pretty prominently
that is true chad and i uh wrote and
produced a pilot years and years ago
with the old
columbia broadcasting system
cbs and uh in that show there was an
atlantis thing at the very beginning and
the end
oh yeah that's right the cold open and
the tag it was the main characters were
in a best buy yeah playing guitar hero
to you ought to know and now years later
here we are covering it on doozy
isn't it ironic don't you think
here's what you do
please tell a friend
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break the
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell open then